can you share with us one of your
earliest memory
okay
I'm picture right now those antique
furniture from my grandma's house in the
city of Hermosillo Mexico like imagine
them oak Oak and other kinds of wood
lots of force Lando's many porcelain
figurines the smell stagnant smell of
old furniture with the kitchen with
grandmother's perfume
sometimes it robs you oxygen from your
head and makes you dizzy at a
fraction of a second but you think you
get like used to it and kind of forget
about it after after I would play with my
brothers sisters and cousins where which
were also around the same age just running around
earliest memories
is when I misspell pomegranate the first
time and it was like something right P
U M O or something very terrible and that's
literally my first memory and I mean I
can't believe it but it's okay I mean we
all make mistakes right when I were
young actually my brother he
used to sell dates in the street so when
he came back at home he lets me
he let me pick the rotten dates from
like a thousand thousand dates that was
very awful and I was crying and I didn't
wanted to do it but I was offered to do
it's a bad memory but..
so that was your job was to pick the rotten ones?... yeah. and
he would go and sell the good ones?... yeah.
He go to sleep but I picked the rotten
my cousin his name is Gerald and he stole my  scooter and then the next like two hours
or so he got ran over by a car and he
broke his foot so that's the earliest I
remember but I was really mad because he
stole my scooter but then I felt sorry
because I went to the hospital and he
broke his foot so... karma huh?!
this is
really funny one... when I was around like four or five I had just discovered
the F word and
I was in the back of my house and I I
don't know I was really distressed and
my dad he came to the back
he wanted me to do something but I
didn't want to do it so I just said f*** it
and that was my first
beating of my life but it was very
memorable because I felt like the f-word
was very liberating... and...
just in the moment it was like a feeling
that I didn't want to do it and it would
make me happier the same the f-word so I said it
one of my earliest memories I was when I was probably three years old we had
a wood-burning stove and my mother was
stoking it for the evening and she put
in some kerosene and it exploded on her
face and she put on a salve called
---------  and then she came
to kiss me good night
yeah I was in my little crib and she
had it looked to me like she had a
relish spread all over her face it was
scary and then it was funny
okay so when I was like like a baby like two or three years old I was lying down on the bed and I placed myself in a weird position
and I just kept thinking to myself okay
years from now I'm gonna remember this
very memory of me lying down weirdly on
the bed and that's my earliest memory
I remember like when I was about two
years old
crawling around on the floor
just around like my house kind of
I don't know I think there's a lot of
going on at my house at that time and so
I think I just was kind of picking up on
the energy in the house
what kind of energy was it? not good negative
family trouble when I was that age my
mom was going through a lot with my dad and yeah..
seeing my friend commit suicide when I
was young I guess that's probably like
one of the things that stuck with me my
entire life and I don't know it's never went away
so it's crazy because I can
answer this immediately because it was so
traumatic actually but my earliest
memory is getting into a really bad car
accident
my mom was hit by a drunk driver and I
remember being in the car crying and we
had all these people coming up to the
windows and I was hysterical
but I was the only one who wasn't hurt
so I don't know why I was crying
that much but I was four and I remember
being put in the stretcher and having my
neck held down and I was very confused and that's my first memory
I think my parents putting me to bed one
night and I could see them both in the doorway
why does that stand out to you?
it's one of the few times I actually saw them
like hugging I guess I don't know
it's a scary memory when I was in California for the
first time and my family was walking in
front of me they were like busy already
and the elevator door closed in
front of me so it started going up like
12 stories so I thought I was gone
forever I was gonna just keep going up
so I fell asleep in the elevator because
they got so scared
well more like fainted and then when I
woke up I was in the car and they didn't
even explain what happened that's pretty much it
shoving a bar of soap in my sister's mouth
and making her puke and poop in the tub
I was in as well so it's like my favorite
childhood memory its all i've got. she like
stood up really fast she scraped her
back my mom was so mad it was such a
disgusting bath after that. like blood poop and vomit.
I have a twin sister and we were always
together we were inseparable growing up
and then one day we went to daycare and
a teacher tried to separate us so I
kicked her and I got in trouble but from
that day forward we weren't separated after that so... shows her.
when my sister was
born I was six and I clearly remember
the day she was born and I held her. it
was
the most amazing feeling in the world. Is that your sister?... Yes.
I used to drink soda and like put it in my shirt instead
of my mouth
that's like the earliest memory I remember. what do you mean?
like I used to drink soda and put it
inside of my shirt instead of my mouth
like instead of like opening my mouth up
I would like pour it into my
like chest.. you know what I mean?
yeah that's that's all I can remember
from back then - that's the earliest
memory I remember. I was like four at the
time so it was acceptable I was only four old so...
the first time I rode my dog
sat on his back and rode my dog
I rode him around the
backyard and then I fell off and he came
back around and laid down next to me and
licked me and I got back on him and we
rode around a little longer
listening to
Billy Joel's uptown girl while playing the Gazoo to it and my He-Man drawers
I wasaround like three and my papa, my grandfather, he had this like huge
garden. my child imagination
thinks that like everything under the
Sun grew in there but I'm sure it was
like five things. but I just remember him
handing me like mint and being like eat
this and I'd like chew on the mint and
then he'd be like hand me a tomato be
like eat this and I like to eat the
tomato and like I just remember like
trailing after him in the garden like eating
whatever he handed me and like loving it
and thinking it was like the coolest
It involves me and my dad. I was like younger than three but he's laying on the hammock and
I'm laying on his chest and he's playing
the guitar in our old backyard it's a
really good memory.
why do you think that one stands out to you?
because it's just drawn real close to home you know? Real personal.
Hey guys! Thanks for watching another episode.  I just wanted to come on here real quickand let you guys know that next week
August the 16th will be a pretty special
day because it'll mark exactly one year
since I uploaded my first episode of the
project here on YouTube. Since it will be
pretty important date to me and
hopefully for you guys as well I thought
I'd do an episode that's different than
what I usually do. So I have a little something planned. I haven't filmed it yet
Hopefully it'll turn out good but
just remember that instead of posting
Tuesday next week I'll be posting on
Thursday August the 16th.
For those of you who've been watching since the beginning you will never know how much
it means to me so thank you again and
for those of you who just started
watching my videos thank you as well. I
hope you all find a reason to keep
coming back and watching my episodes
here on YouTube aaaaand that's it.